-Congratulations
on your first season
as a judge on "The Voice."
Last time we saw you,
you were just about to start.
-Yes.
-And are you enjoying it?
-I am having too much fun.
-Too much fun.
-That´s great.
-It´s amazing.
-Do you have a strategy?
Have you developed a strategy?
-[ Sighs ] Yes, I have.
But I don´t want
to give it away,
´cause I know Adam and Blake
both are watching.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
You think like --
So, now, you think...
[ Laughter ]
...they´re so --
they´re so set on winning
that they´re following
your every move.
They´re watching tape on you.
They´re saying, "If we can find
out anything" -- Yeah.
-They might want to watch J-Hud,
you know,
´cause everybody wants to win.
And then you cannot forget --
they´re -- they are the vets.
They´re the bookends
of the show.
-Yeah.
-So they´re a bit
ahead of the game.
And I´m playing catchup.
And when I do,
oh, they better look out.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, interesting.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Interesting.
Do you -- Did --
Now, is someone like Blake --
He´s a very kind person.
-He really is.
-He´s been here,
so I know he´s desperate to win,
but, also, very kind.
Does he gave you any advice
on the coaching side?
-Yeah, he told me once that
I didn´t pitch hard enough.
He´s like, "You got to --
You got to fight, like, battle."
And I´m, like, one minute,
I think I´m coach--
I think I´m pitching,
and I think I´m, like,
battling it out.
And he´s like, "Jennifer,
you´re not pitching hard enough.
You´ve got to go harder."
And I´m like,
"I´m not doing enough?"
Because Miley --
she doesn´t stop.
-Yeah.
-Like, that girl
is a firecracker, y´all.
-Yeah.
-Like, she goes on and on.
And I´ll say my piece, I´ll say
two cents, and I think I´m done.
And Blake is like,
"Jennifer, keep pitching.
You´re not pitching
hard enough."
And I´m like...
And she´s still going.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, that´s very --
I mean, that´s exhausting.
Trying to keep up with Miley
must be exhausting.
-[ Chuckling ] It is.
-She is --
-She can talk!
-I can talk, too,
but she can really talk.
-She can really talk.
She has boundless energy...
-Yes. Yes.
-...in my experiences
with Miley.
You had met her years ago...
-Uh-huh.
-...at
Pharrell´s birthday party.
-[ Chuckles ] Yes.
-By the way, that is where
I want all cool people to meet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Like, that -- that´s
the best place to meet anyone.
-It is,
because Pharrell is cool.
-Yeah, he is the coolest.
-Yeah, she was twerking, though.
-She was twerking.
-And how -- when you saw
her twerking, was your --
Did you think, "Oh,
I should go twerk with her?"
Did you think --
-I tried it.
-You did?
-But that is not for me.
-It didn´t work out?
[ Laughter ]
-It did not work out.
-Interesting.
-I will leave it to Miley.
-Whoa.
-But she had it down. She was
on the floor, everything.
-Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
How quickly --
-Sorry, Miley.
-How quickly into your twerking
did you think,
"Oh, this is not for me"?
-I gave it up quite fast,
because nothing moved.
-Okay.
-My knee.
-Your knee moved?
-Y´all don´t want me to get up
and try to twerk.
I don´t even know what that is.
But, no,
it didn´t work out for me.
-I think, yeah, if your knee
is the only thing moving,
you´re doing it wrong.
-That was the only thing moving.
-And I know very -- I know
very little about twerking.
[ Laughter ]
But I know enough
to know that´s not great.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to see you twerk.
Okay.
-Oh, no, you don´t want
to see me twerk.
If you see me twerk, I will have
to get my ACL replacement.
[ Laughter ]
You did something on the show
that I get --
I will be honest -- you --
you -- you threw your shoe.
This is a photo of you.
Someone was singing.
They finished their song.
I believe it was
"Try a Little Tenderness."
Was that the song?
-Yes.
-Which is --
was incredibly well sung.
And then you threw your shoe,
which -- I will be honest --
if I was onstage
and a shoe came up...
[ Laughter ]
...I´d think that was
an unsatisfied customer.
-No!
-Okay, interesting.
-It is a compliment.
-Well, at J-Hud Productions,
it´s a compliment.
-Gotcha.
-Come on, now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you move me enough
that I remove my shoe
to throw it at you,
you have done something
just amazing.
-That´s fanta--
-Like, it´s equivalent
to a standing ovation.
-Interesting.
-Yeah.
-Has this been your --
Has anyone
ever thrown a shoe at you?
-Oh, yes.
-Okay.
-I did -- I had an audition
for a tour with Barry Manilow,
like, I don´t know
how many years ago that was.
And I sang a song.
And the people who
I was auditioning in front of --
they literally threw everything
at me off of the desk.
-Wow!
[ Light laughter ]
-And I was just standing there
like, "Oh, my God."
It was shoes. It was notebooks.
It was pens and everything.
They was like,
"Girl, you better sing!"
[ Laughter ]
-That´s great.
-So when somebody´s singing
for me...
-You get -- yeah.
-...you might catch a shoe.
And if I could get this boot off
right now...
-Yeah, well, that´s --
[ Laughter ]
Now, this is interesting,
because was noticing your boots
as you came in.
It would seem -- Now, do you
ever think before a night,
"Hey, I might see something
I really like.
I should wear shoes
that are easy to get off"?
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, I´ll say this.
If I -- If I -- the next time
I go to see you live,
I´m just gonna wear Crocs,
´cause I want to get them --
get them off.
[ Laughter ]
They´re soft.
If I should accidentally hit you
in the head, you´ll be fine.
-Maybe I should carry one
in my purse.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah, exactly.
Well, that would be great.
A purse shoe --
that´s what you need.
[ Laughter ]
-A purse shoe.
-And then people will say,
"Did Jennifer like you?"
And they´ll say,
"Well, she threw a shoe,
but it was in her purse."
-"She threw a shoe."
Right, right.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But I would bring one.
But, no, I don´t,
because it´s --
it comes from, like -- music is
so moving and powerful to me...
-Uh-huh.
-...that it literally dictates
my every emotion.
And I don´t even know
I threw my shoe at you.
-Oh, really?
-And if you´re close enough,
you might get hit.
But it´s a compliment.
-Oh, so you´re like --
You, like, have a moment
where you are out of body.
-I am out of body.
-Yeah.
-Like the time when I threatened
Blake and Adam on the show
and I told them,
"Don´t you turn around."
-[ Laughs ]
-Like, that --
It was like
an out-of-body experience.
Like, "I´m so sorry.
I didn´t mean to hit you.
I didn´t mean to threaten you.
I didn´t mean to throw a shoe."
[ Laughter ]
But it´s just how
the song moves me, music --
Y´all might understand --
the band.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Like, music moves me
in a unique, special way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well --
-But it´s all
out of passion and love.
-And I can say,
of the times that
I´ve been lucky enough
to see you sing live,
there is no one who is as moving
when they sing as you.
-Thank you.
-And so, it is just such a
pleasure as always to see you.